(upbeat music)
- First off I have this avocado gadget.
It slices it with this, it pits it
and then you can slice it with this thing.
- I'm literally just using a knife
because I don't need help
to try to open an avocado.
To test it we're going to see
who can cut three avocados the fastest.
(upbeat music)
- Really, what do you do
when you get to the end?
(upbeat music)
- Done!
- Okay.
A little behind.
The cutting part was easy,
taking the pit out was easy
but as you can see the slicing
part is not easy nor pretty.
(upbeat music)
Up next we're hard boiling some eggs
and I am using this rapid egg cooker.
- And I'm just using a good
old pot of boiling water.
- So to use this little guy
you have to first fill it up
with the amount of water that you want.
So we want hard boiled eggs
so I filled it up to the top.
Pour the water in there but
a key stop is making sure
that you put little, tiny
holes in the top of the egg
and there's a little
puncture on the bottom.
(upbeat music)
- Oh my God, it's a fire alarm.
- They both made good eggs
but I think this has a built-in timer.
You literally put the eggs on
and don't have to worry about it.
- Yeah and I think, considering the time
you have to wait to boil water,
this actually would be faster.
So I think for this round, Keyla you won.
- Next we're going to be
taking corn off of the cob
and I have this corn stripper
which is going to just
literally take the corn off.
- So I'm gonna be using the scary knife
and I'm gonna be making four
cuts to take the corn off
instead of using that mouse.
(upbeat music)
- Oh my.
- Done.
- I struggled and I think
part of the reason why
was this wasn't as sharp as
I thought it was going to be.
A lot of it was falling
on the cutting board.
So yeah, that one just didn't work for me.
I am using herb scissors.
- And shocker, I am using this knife.
One, two, three.
(upbeat music)
Done.
So for the scissor round, I
think it's actually a tie.
Keyla won with the green onions.
- Wait, wait, wait, can
you say that on more time?
- Keyla won and I think
I won with the parsley.
- I'm going to use this
microwave pasta boat.
To use this microwave pasta boat
you first want to measure out your pasta
and they have this cool thing.
It's a handle that measures
two serving sizes of past.
I filled it up to the two mark
because I have two serving sizes.
(upbeat music)
Tadah!
- It's not bad.
It's actually cooked really well.
It's not overcooked.
- It cooked all the way through.
- Yeah, and it's like al dente.
I'd prefer to eat this one.
- Yeah.
Pasta boat, who knew?
(upbeat music)
- I guess that means we tied today.
- We tied.
I honestly thought I was going to lose.
- I honestly thought I was going to win.
(upbeat music)